[Music]
my talk is entitled the uncanny valley
this comes from a concept that was
introduced in the 1970s by the robotics
professor Masahiro mori and this has to
do with our response our emotional
responses to robots as they progress
from being completely machine like to
fully human
so along an axis of anthropomorphism and
it appears that in terms of how we react
to them if they're completely machine
light we're very happy we accept them as
they are and we don't feel freaked out
by them and of course if they happen to
be fully human then we treat them as we
do other humans however and as they get
progressively more human we tend to
think of them as being more like us but
then rather paradoxically there comes a
point when they are sort of almost all
too human they look human that they look
like us but they aren't us in a way that
really freaks us out and so he pointed
out that there came as you added realism
this rather unusual dip where too much
realism actually reversed our response
to these creatures
and we start to find them rather spooky
so this some wonderful sort of concept
actually extends to how we respond to it
to a range of other phenomena where you
can have can go from something very
abstract and progressively add realism
so for example dolls
once again you can see you can have a
very simple doll just such as this rag
doll shown here say does this work and
our response to very simple kind of very
abstract kind of dolls it is usually one
that that some we have very pleasant
response to them certainly the babies
that we offer them to tend to identify
them quite easily and then dolls of
course can become more and more
realistic and generally speaking we
don't find them unpleasant until they
hit again that kind of boundary where
they start to look just a little too
much like us without being us and so
there again you can have this phenomenon
of the uncanny valley
indeed I use this kind of concept to
make clear a very fundamental aspect of
mathematical models which when I speak
for example my students and that is the
point the mathematical mathematical
models are abstractions and not replicas
so here we have staying continuing to
sort of remain in the realm of toys we
have two toy cars and the one on the
left is of course a very serious
abstraction it's it's a very very simple
model of a car that doesn't really
resemble a car to any great extent
whereas the one to the right looks is a
convincing sort of replica of a car but
in terms of what is more useful it
actually boils down to what features it
possesses that would for example allow a
child who is playing with it to gain
some kind of understanding of our car
functions so it might be the case that
the car on the left although it doesn't
look anything like a car has wheels that
move where
the car on the right although it looks a
lot like a car doesn't have wheels that
move in which case the car on the Left
would be a better model for a car as
such than the car on the right which
resembles a real car in well plus Li so
in other words when you think of a model
you can arrange models on a scale of
complexity where they go from being very
very simple to ones that have more
features that to all intents and
purposes align them more closely with
something that is real so if you think
of reality as what we're trying to
understand you can move from something
that is very abstract to something that
more closely resembles reality and
certainly if you can completely
replicate reality itself then that would
be a very useful model so if you think
of models as being a red and in terms of
their complexity and think of their
utility so you start with something very
very basic and abstract and as you move
along on the spectrum of complexity you
might expect that they become more
useful as you add more features or add
more realism a term that's often used
but the example that I gave in the
previous slide actually also shows that
if you add too much realism or the wrong
kinds of realism you can end up as
easily as with the the robotics or
whether ever more realistic dolls you
can end up in what I would call the
uncanny valley of mathematical modeling
where you create something that looks a
lot like reality but in fact is far less
useful than the simple abstraction
so how does all this help us make sense
of what's happening out there right now
how does that help us make design ways
out of the predicament that we're in
well let's look at what we have here and
how we can use mathematical models to
try and understand it there's a long
tradition of using mathematical models
to understand the spread of an
infectious diseases but these models are
rooted in theoretical ecology an
infectious disease is a product of an
interaction between two species the
pathogen in this case the Kovach virus
and the host
not very we're not gracious hosts to the
covert virus but we are the host the
human host and because it is an
interaction between the two species at
the language of theoretical ecology and
the models that theoretical ecologists
use are actually very helpful in
shedding light on the dynamics of the
systems so what you do what that process
entails is building a model and then
trying to fit that model to look at the
behavior of that model and see what it's
how closely it approximates what we know
about the disease what so what do we
know
and the idea is once you have a model
and it does something behaves like what
we know about the data then we can make
some inferences that will help us to a
understand how the disease is working
and be how we can control it so what do
we know about this epidemic where we
epidemic in this country pandemic
because it's a it's a global problem so
what but these are data from the UK and
what this does that the graph on your
left does is it shows you how the deaths
from kovat 19 which is the the disease
caused by this new virus SARS kovat
corona virus - how that has unfolded in
the UK so we had cases we started to
detect deaths from this disease in early
March and that then rose rapidly 23rd of
March we instituted lockdown and since
then we've seen the deaths increase as
we would expect them to lockdown or not
because there is a delay between when
you get infected and when you get
diseased and they'd peaked around
mid-april I mean early 12th April and
then started to come down and
unfortunately declining have been
declining since the other graph here is
shows the same data on the right hand
side but as a cumulative mortality curve
so just showing you how those deaths is
stacking up through time rather than
their incidence to continue watching
this video click the link in the top
left or in the description below or
visit a IDOT TV for more debates and
talks from the world's leading thinkers
on today's biggest ideas